what do you make of consciousness for
example
there's something as an example of
something we completely have no clue
about
the fact that we have this subjective
experience right is it possible that
this
network of uh this circuit of switches
is able to create something like
consciousness
to know its own identity yeah to know to
know the algorithm
to know itself to know itself
i think if you try to define that
rigorously you'd have a lot of trouble
yeah that's interesting so
i know that there are um many
who um
believe that general
intelligence can be achieved and there
are even some who are
feel certain that
the singularity will come and we will be
surpassed by the machines which will
then
learn more and more about themselves and
reduce humans to an
inferior breed i am doubtful that this
will
ever be achieved just for the fun of it
could you linger on why
what's your intuition why you're
doubtful so there are
quite a few people that are extremely
worried about this
uh existential threat of artificial
intelligence of us being
left behind by the super intelligent
new species what's your intuition why
that's not
quite likely
just because none of the achievements in
speech or robotics or
natural language processing or creation
of
flexible computer assistance or any of
that comes
anywhere near close to
that level of cognition
what do you think about ideas as a sort
of uh if we look at moore's law
and exponential improvement uh to allow
us to
that would surprise us sort of our
intuition fall apart with with
exponential improvement
because i mean we're not able to kind of
we kind of think in linear improvement
yeah we're not able to imagine a world
that goes from the
mark one computer to an iphone 10.
yeah so do you think it would be we
could be really surprised
by the exponential growth or
or on the flip side is is it possible
that also intelligence is
actually way way way way harder
even with exponential improvement to be
able to crack
i don't think any constant factor
improvement
could could change
things and given given our current
comprehension
of how the of of
of what cognition requires it seems to
me that
multiplying the speed of the switches by
a factor of a thousand or a million
will not be useful until we really
understand the organizational principle
behind
the network of switches
you